és it még egy másik gondolatot elmondané
kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre
hogy az emberiség tehát az iu az egyik
legbiztosabb
ilyen előrejelzője a a szakmai sikernek
tehát hogy ez ez egy nagyon
nagyon fájdalmas információ de tényleg
az van hogy akikn magasabb az iq-ja
statisztikailag könnyebben boldogulnak a
világban és ez ez úgy is megjelenik hogy
például a hadsereg 83 iq alatt már nem
vesz be senkit a az amerikai hadseregről
beszélek azért 83 mert azt látták hogy
83 ik alatt nem tudnak semmi olyan
munkát adni annak a személynek hogy hogy
az produktívan el tudja végezni és ez
egy nagyon fájdalmas kutatási eredmény
mert egyrészt nem szívesen hallja ezt
senki és a másik pedig az hogy nem
tudunk mit kezdeni ezzel és az
embereknek a ti pár százaléka 83 io
alatt van ez egy az ik az egy
természetes eloszlást mutat tehát ez a
gauszgörbe az a haranggőbe ki lehet
számolni elég pontosan azt hogy káb hány
embernek van 100 a közepe amúgy az
iq-nak és kábé ki lehet számolni azt
hogy 83 iq alatt hány ember van és azt
látom hogy ahogy a világunk egyre
gyorsabbá válik és egyre komplexebbé
válik talán ez a belépési küszöb egyre
magasabban lesz tehát már lehet nem lesz
elegendő 83ikor 84 85-re lesz szükség ha
most az ördög ügyvédjét kell játszam így
a technológiával szemben akkor ez lenne
az egyik pont ami ami ami megkérdezném a
te véleményedet hogy vajon neme azt
fogja okozni hogy egyre nagyobb réteg
lesz az aki viszont nem fog tudni a
versenyszférába labdába rúgni mert túl
sok túl komplexzé válik a világunk és
egy szűk kisebbsége a az emberiségnek
hiperproduktív lesz aki eddig is
produktív volt az még produktívabbá
válik még több mindent el fog tudni
végezni és és egy egy egy egyre nagyobb
és növekvő kisebbség mert azér még
mindig kisebbség egyre jobban ki lesz
téve annak hogy már nem nagyon fog tudni
mit csinálni mert nem lesz munka
számára hm hát a a kérdésedben az hiszem
hogy implicit az is benne van hogy akkor
hogyan hogy hogy mi a mi lenne az
esztimáció vagy az előrejelzés hogy
hogyan fogja igazából a munkaerőpiacot
átalakítani ez asolút ez az ai hogy
akkor tényleg az lesz-e hogy akkor
megszűnnek munkakörök vagy pont hogy
több munka több több munkahely fog le
nek újak azok azok tényleg ilyen
magasabb bíkú vagy magasabb szakmai
felkészültséget fognak-e
igényelni én azt gondolom hogy ez egy ez
egy ez egy összetettebb dolog és sok
szempontból árnyalatabb merthogy hogy
hogy
hogy függ attól hog melyik milyen
munkakörre milyen hatással lesz tehát a
a értelemszerűen lesz át fogja alakítani
a már átalakította és ugyanúgy ahogy
eddig is átalakította a technológiai
fejlődés a munkaerőpiacot ugyanígy így
át fogja alakítani a következőkben és és
ilyen szempontból persze az ai-nak is
megvan és meglesz a
az impaktja most milyen munkakörök
fognak megszűnni tehát alapból azt
tudjuk mondani hogy azok a munkakörök
amelyek könnyebben automatizálhatóak
tehát például amik valamilyen repetitív
ismételhető munkáról szólnak azok
nagyobb eséllyel lesznek ugye
robotizálva vagy helyettesítve
robotok
által de ez nem feltétlenül jelenti
egyrészt hogy hogy ez ezzel együtt meg
fognak jelenni teljesen új munkakörök
amiket most még nem is feltétlenül
tudunk pontosan hogy azok hogy fognak
kinézni másrészt ez egyáltalán nem azt
jelenti hogy akkor most csak a nem tudom
a magas
felkészültségűget igénylő nem tudom hogy
értelmiségi szakmák maradnak meg és
akkor a másik oldalról tehát mondjuk
ugye e a kék galléros vonalról tűnnek el
a sőt sőt tehát hogy
és nem is egyik napról a másikra fog
azért ez ez ez ez bekövetkezni
én próbálnék egy picit ilyen optimistább
nézőpontot képviselni ugye annak idején
is nagy felháborodás egészen
tüntetésekig
elmenő felháborodás övezte ugye a
mosógépek mosógép megjelenését ugye
akkor is sokan azt vizionálták hogy
akkor eznek most nagyon óriási
társadalmi impaktja lesz megszűnnek a
munkahelyek moson munkahelyei és és és
és akkor ja mi lesz és és és való igaz
megszűntek de megjelentek új tehát
átalakult tudott alkalmazkodni a a
társadalom én nagyon remélem vagy merem
remélni hogy a ez a technológiával és a
mesterséges intelligenciával is ugyanígy
fog történni csak ez nem fog magától
történni tehát ehhez nekünk tennünk kell
hogy itt
itt tudjunk úgymond adaptálódni igen át
fog alakulni a munkaerőpiac de most
néhány évvel ezelőtt amikor amikor
megjelentek az első automata nem tudom
kasszák vagy akár full automatizált
teljesen automatizált üzletek akkor
akkor akkor mindenki azt vizionálta hogy
akkor most nem lesz szükség
kasszásokra az üzletekbe nem ez történt
igaz megjelentek a a az automatizált
terminálok és igen megjelentek teljesen
automatizált üzletek de továbbra is
szüksé csak szükség van a az emberi
jelenlétre az önvezető autók környékén
amikor nagyon hype volt néhány évvel
ezelőtt egyébként itt is egy zárójelként
igazából megint az hogy azt mondtuk hogy
régre nyúlnak vissza a gyökerek mer a
80-as években is intenzíven kutatták az
önvezető autókat sőt már 0-as években
volt
működő neurális hálózat által vezetett
ön önvezetett autó igaz hogy még jó nagy
volt szegény mert sok hardvert rá
kellett pakolni és igaz hogy még csak
egy előre kijelőlt pályán tudott menni
nagyon kicsi sebességgel tehát
semmiképpen nem összehasonlítható a mai
technológiával de már ott megvoltak a
gyökerei ezeknek a történeteknek zárójel
bezárva visszatérve ugye az önvezető
autóknak a fejlődésével ugye viszonálták
hogy néhány év múlva már nem lesz
szükség sofőrökre elérhetünk addig a
pontig ameddig kevesebbre lesz szükség
tehát amikor tényleg logisztikában
szállításban is elterjedt bb lesz már a
mesterséges de még de még nem tartunk
ott és nem egyik napról a másikra fog ez
lezajlani egyébként van egy ilyen
weboldal is az érdekesség kedvére hogy a
a mondom itt a hallgatóknak hogyha meg
akarják nézni akkor van egy ilyen hogy
hogy hogy elveszik-e a robotok a
munkahelyinket munkas akkor ez különböző
ilyen valószínűséget számít nem tudom
pontosan a módszertan mi alapján
gyanítom hogy visszajelzések tehát hogy
felhasználói feedbackek alapján hogy
akkor mennyi a valószínűsége hogy hogy
elvesszük elv az adott munka körömet a
mesterséges intelligencián a de ez is ha
néha megnézed ezt a weboldalt nagyon
változó most például jelen pillanatban
nagyjából azt látnánk rajta hogy az
informatikusok vannak a a legnagyobb
veszélyben
és ez ez sem és és vannak olyanok akik
tényleg azt mondják hogy hát itt két
éven belül már nem lesz szükség
programozókra mert mindent a az ai fog
megírni én ezt is árnyaltabbá látom
árnyaltabbnak látom tehát igen
meglesz a a az impaktja a történetek de
nem az ez nem azt jelenti hogy akkor
kész nincsen szükségünk programozókra
utána nincsen szükségünk architektekre
nincsen szükségünk emberi jelenlétre
hogyha belegondolunk egyébként már 20
évvel ezelőtt is vagy 30 évvel ezelőtt
is voltak olyan eszközeink amelyek
hatékonyabbá tették a munkánkat akárhogy
csak a saját munkánknál mondjuk a
programozásnál informatikánál maradok
ugye jelentek meg a jobbnál jobb
fejlesztői környezetek amik
hatékonyabbnál kényelmesebbé tették a
fejlesztést utána meg jelentek már vagy
használtunk már tien évvel ezelőtt is
olyan automatizált kódgenerátor
eszközöket amelyek gyakorlatilag egy
teljes projektvázát tudták nekünk
automatikusan generálni tehát az
egyszerű rutin feladatoknál tudták
helyettesíteni a programozót
de példaként hogy ez ezekre én a a a
tanítványoknak aoktatásban is mindig azt
mondom hogy ezek ezek nem ördögvó
ördögtől valóak ezek a sőt ezek azokzért
voltak kitalálva hogy a munkánkat
hatékonyabbá tegyék akkor használjuk
ezeket de csak akkor használjunk egy
ilyen eszközt hogyha értjük hogy hogy
hogyan működik tehát például akkor
használjun egy kód generátor eszközt
amikor megértettük azt a kódot amitátévé
vált váltunk annak amit kigeneráltát is
meg tudunk írni egy il hanem hanem akkor
elvesztődtünk hanem akkor amikor utána
azt módosítani kell vagy amikor be kell
nyúlni úgymond a motorháztető alá akkor
ak akkor nem lesz mit mit tennünk tehát
hogy attól függetlenül hogy ezek az
eszközök hatékonyabbá kényelmesebbé
teszik a munkánkat attól függetlenül
nekünk még szükségünk van a tudásra sőt
még többre van szükségünk hogy értsük
azt hogy hogy hogy mi van ezeknek a
hátterében hogy megfelelően tudjuk
használni ezeket és ezek ezek tényleg
eszközök legyenek a kezünkben amik
hatékonyabbá teszik a a teszik a a
munkánkat most igen ez azt fogja
jelenteni
hogy többet tehát hogy hatékonyabb
eszközeink vagyunk vannak akkor többet
tudunk több munkát tudunk elvégezni és
akkor a kérdésedre visszatérve akkor ez
azt jelenti hogy hogy hogy kevesebb
lesz-e a a munkaerő vagy csökken ezáltal
a munkaerő igény vagy akármilyen
esélyeik vannak akkor a mondjuk a
mondjuk a junioroknak
ilyen szempontból a azt gondolom hogy
lesz egy impaktja vagy van már és lesz
egy impaktja ennek a ennek a történetnek
de
de szerintem stabilizálódni is fog tehát
pont azért mert megjelennek teljesen új
munkakörök is ezáltal
én azt gondolom hogy mindenki meg tudja
találni a a helyét hogyha odafigyel erre
arra hogy odafigyel erre tiszta és
világos szerintem hogy itt itt egy
kicsit tehát hogy hogy rengeteg
tanulásra van szükségess egy kicsit
másfajta kompetenciák kerülnek előtérbe
mint mondjuk régen gondolok itt arra
hogy nagyon-nagyon fontos lesz az hogy
hogy hogy hogy adaptálódni tudjunk
ezekhez a nagyon nagyon nagyon gyors
válto változásokhoz
nagyon-nagyon szükséges lesz az hogy
hogy hogy csapatban tudjunk dolgozni
hogy hogy az együttműködés kultúráját
úgymond úgymond megértsük és és
alkalmazzuk a a kommunikációnak a
kreatív ágazatoknak a ez a stem vagy
steam ez a science technology
engineeringen met ágazatoknak tehát
ezeknek lesz kiemelt vagy ezeknek már
kiemelt a jelentősége ilyen ilyen
szempontból hogy tudjunk alkalmazkodni
ezekhez a folyamatokhoz ezekhez a
változásokhoz